three-two-one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast you know what's poppin on
Thursdays we got Joe jisu [ __ ]
Japanese at how ha hello everybody oh
man man man so uh so we only talked
about this briefly but so you guys know
that I uh that we we decided to get this
office outside of my apartment which is
really great and before I decided to do
that I was thinking about bringing
somebody onto this podcast and I was
like oh you know some people who I don't
know which I kind of figured out that it
was a little weird when I bring people
over to an apartment where first of all
Muriel's not entertainment yeah and then
I have a bunch of strangers coming in
yeah it is weird but I mean [ __ ]
Bobby does it all the tags Oh Bobby's
also the weirdest person in the room so
that's different they're not true
they're probably scared to come into his
apartment it's the other way around
honey cause like he has an apartment
right yeah he has these like he's
friends with all these celebrities
mm-hmm so first off I don't feel like
these celebrities would be scary to
bring into your house yeah so that's I
think that's the safe part right the
other part though is that to me it's he
lives like a child that's true he's 10
years older than us he's he's got so
much action figures and it feels like a
kid's [ __ ] home it's fun yeah it's
like one of those things when you walk
in you're like man do I think I live
like this in college and I miss it yeah
yeah it's like a college dorm room it's
like you never grew up do shoutouts to
Bobby Lee and Tiger belly man one of the
funniest [ __ ] podcasts out there dude
yeah but I feel like safe because if all
of my guests are celebrities I'll bring
them into my house that's true yeah but
then in our case like you might bring a
random person yeah so uh people I've
been actually wondering about this and
it took me a while to think about it I
was like because I always like to try to
come from a place of like empathy
because when people are acting
erratically or some or you know what I
like to call batshit [ __ ] crazy yeah
there's there's always a reason for it
right there's a reason why people behave
the way that they do something that
happened in their past so I decided to
have it in a public office space because
number one there's cameras here yeah
that means there's timestamps that means
if somebody tries to pull some crazy
stupid [ __ ] yes what [ __ ] shit's
recorded and I gots proof so I decided
to have somebody on this podcast who I I
met randomly and it turns out this
person isn't feeling like the adult
entertainment industry and that that
podcast interview went to [ __ ] it was
you threw it away I I still have it just
in case but now I'm not gonna put it out
ya whatsoever but it was one of those
weird things and I had to tell Joe about
this because like I got listen I don't
get freaked out or scared by a lot of
things right specifically when it comes
to me being in danger just because I
didn't grow up in a nice area I know
what danger feels like and I'm smart
about my [ __ ]
but when it comes to crazy that's a
whole different level of crazy feels
different man yeah I felt so [ __ ]
unsafe yeah and and here's the weird
part about it so when we were conducting
this interview and you guys have all
heard of these genius brain podcasts I
don't come in here with an agenda there
is no agenda it's just conversation and
stuff that I want to know about and I'll
talk about it I'm not trying to get like
clickbait eviews though the titles are
settling I don't write to tell us by the
way so it's just conversation and
sometimes great things come out
sometimes it doesn't it sometimes just
something that people just want to hear
I mean you'd have you actually had to
scratch so many episodes you wasted
several hours with so many episodes that
just didn't work out that's what people
don't know yeah is that you only go for
the gold conversations yeah cuz there
are just some that did not work out yeah
and it's also - because when I bring
people on I don't want them to look bad
so if I put it out and sometimes I feel
like you said kind of some kind of
salacious [ __ ]
yeah it's you're not gonna look good on
this and you're not very good at
speaking on the mic so it just makes you
look stupid I'm not gonna put this out
because I asked you to come onto this
podcast so I don't want you walk away
looking terrible and so with this person
essentially you know being in the
basically with the adult entertainment
industry what I wanted to find out is
why someone who in this space like
specifically in you know we're in
YouTube right so YouTube we were allowed
to create our own destiny and so I feel
like that kind of translates with girls
who are who are cam girls cam girls they
can control their income and figure out
what they want to make and how they want
to make it yeah take a self promote and
it's there's there's really no overhead
to it but
the camera that you know you're [ __ ]
around on so what would make somebody
who is a very popular person on a cam
girl site go go off and to be a
professional in in the porn industry
like what's the list of money disparity
when they went from cam girl to port
yeah and then amateur to pro oh wow so I
wanted to know what that process was
like and why would you go from that when
you have so much control here it's the
money that much better doesn't open up
doors for you that's where the
conversation was was going to lead yeah
you know but we didn't even get past to
that it was it was like simple question
it was like what's your name where are
you from and I was like well honey I'm
not gonna disclose that [ __ ] yeah and it
was her name what why would you ask me
said it's a personal [ __ ] yeah
and so you know after the podcast was
over essentially this girl was very
erratic and she was really all over the
place
Wow and I wasn't gonna use that because
she doesn't look good you know it's like
if I ask you a question and then you go
on 13 different tangents and you're not
answering the question and by the way
these questions aren't even harsher
personal and if you don't want to answer
them you don't so for example how'd you
get into the porn industry yeah I
thought that was a very simple question
and so after after I asked Mia that she
was like oh the scouter came some simple
[ __ ] you know and so like I don't I
don't try to make anyone what the [ __ ]
you know and so I basically after it was
over I I asked her I was like hey do you
deal with anxiety issues because I have
anxiety as well that's why I take like a
CBD drops and and you know I walk I
learn how to really relax because it
seems like you were very anxious and you
didn't want to answer these very simple
questions you know and and for her she
goes like yeah I deal with anxiety and
she started going on a diatribe about
her personal issues which I never asked
you know I just asked I was just trying
to calm her down and relax she starts
crying whoa yeah she starts crying and
on the podcast no not on the podcast I
didn't record this part and so you know
she starts crying and then starts
telling me about all these like really
just too personal stuff that I
personally don't feel comfortable even
listening to and so I was like okay I'm
gonna call you Hoover home right so she
was like yeah can you call me an uber
and I was gonna call her an uber either
way because I wanted to have a timestamp
of why she left you know so I you know
called her an uber Comfort bye
which is really nice you know Center
sent her back home um the prior to that
she was asking like you know do you
wanna
are you hungry do you want to eat and
I'm like no no I don't wanna hang out
with you yeah I was like no I'm good and
I'm by the way she also had her other
friend here too
Oh cuz you know be comfortable ya know
bring somebody here that you know like
why not but this is in a public office
space like nothing's gonna happen but so
her friend was on the podcast as well
and she seemed very common well-adjusted
but she wasn't and his two people on the
park it was two people on the podcast
and so you know my thing is to make this
situation very comfortable but then when
she was kind of broke down it was a
little hysterical I sent her on her way
home and she kept on asking if I wanted
to go eat and I was like nah don't like
I already ate I didn't eat but I'm too
scared to eat [ __ ] why don't you
[ __ ] realize that exactly and she was
like oh yeah and I wanted to eat Korean
food sauce showing her a few different
spots and she goes oh I guess like I
just saved money I don't want to spend
money on food I was like oh so you
wanted me to buy you a meal oh is that
what it was yes that's what I was like
then why'd you ask what you wanted to go
eat okay you want to go out you want me
to buy you and your friend dinner right
and I was like nah like what the [ __ ]
like this I just spent like an hour and
a half here you were crying you're all
over the place which is okay cuz this is
this is not your space so world I'm fine
with that
afterwards I packed after we left that
was just very straightforward with her I
said you know you were I said she was
all over the place a little bit and I'll
decide whether I'm gonna use most like
most likely I'm not gonna use this but
if you want to give this another try you
can and I gave her that opportunity just
because you know why not not everybody
is gonna you know knock this out the
park and I think she does have a very
interesting story but then she came back
where she goes well if I do come back I
want to be compensated for my time I
wanted like you know just kind of coming
at me like super aggressive I was like
yo she goes over well maybe you need to
find somebody who's more used to the
space instead of find somebody who
hasn't done this before and I'm like uh
where's this coming from was her friend
like watching the whole time like what
the [ __ ] or yeah I'm I mean I
she was seem pretty fine too and she
actually hit me up the other day asking
if they can come back on and on why
would they want what I don't think she
knows how hard her friend came at me
like she came at me super [ __ ] hard
so I don't think she really realized
like how aggressive she came at me
afterwards and I was still very nice and
cordial I was like no I'm okay I'm not
gonna use the episode don't worry have a
happy new year and then she sends this
other text message after that where it
goes into a lot of her personal issues
that I didn't ask about and she was like
I wasn't gonna tell this I was like I
never knew about this I wasn't asking
you about this stuff what are you saying
did you know when I was seven years old
there were monsters in my class nobody
and I was like oh she's she's kind of
erratic you know anything so she's
definitely dealing with some other
issues so that's what makes the best
entertainment you know like I still want
to protect her image because she's still
a person and I just don't want to air
out people's like dirt that yes she
scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me and at
that point too I'm like hmm it's funny
how all the conversations and the stuff
that we're texting about it seems like
you're trying to get me caught up on
some [ __ ] so I got freaked out and
then you know she started messaging
people about you know certain
whereabouts like or what's genius brain
really a safe place I was like all the
episodes are up it's a very safe place
like safe place what are you talking
about this is a public office space I
was like and you had your friend here I
don't know it's an office that's crazy
it's an office space where other people
rent out there's people here who just
ran into a interesting character man
yeah so she was like trying to get she's
troubled she's a troubled soul yeah and
I think she was like trying to extort me
and I really yeah that's what it felt
like
I'm not these aren't facts but that's
what I [ __ ] found like and I got
freaked out because I know of personal
stories where guys have talked to women
who put them in very uncomfortable
situations right and so I was like is
this happening to me
me of all people I would be mad I'll be
like we didn't even look and I was like
how dare you yeah I was I was freaked
the [ __ ] out so at that point too I was
like you know what these conversations
are getting out of hand I'm trying to
keep really cordial so I had to block
her from from everything mm-hmm I just
leave it at that and then her friend
messaged me saying they want to give it
another chance I get what we're about
you know getting that paper and being
like no getting that paper yes like you
know promoting themselves oh no this is
not a platform for you to promote
yourself like that and if you
were that you had the opportunity before
but then your friend came at me super
super wrong started talking about you
know you're your friend was basically
trying to extort me and now you want to
come back onto this podcast
are you [ __ ] insane people are people
are like out there man I scared the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out if that's why you don't
get super famous is because like if you
did exploit this you put that [ __ ]
commentary you showed the conversation
that [ __ ] will get so many hits
yeah that is good entertainment it is I
know you're out here
you [ __ ] big-hearted [ __ ]
you're out here protecting this [ __ ]
that almost extorted your ass you know
what it seems like cuz I I followed up
and I fought like a couple of my friends
white told us to they sent me her her
other media stuff yeah and they go yo
she is very not well-adjusted and I look
at somebody like that and like something
[ __ ] happen to you in your past so
you feel bad I feel bad and so and this
girl specifically is an Asian American
person so I thought that would be a very
interesting story I don't see a lot of
Asian American girls who hit porn
specifically because I was across I
killed it
Oh awesome but she was like you're
[ __ ] murdered porn yet and how many
like she became a household name I know
I suck era dude DVD Sao there yes so
it's like I was like wondering like what
was her route well why does she get into
this industry yes especially because she
was an Asian American it was very very
interesting man this podcast is brought
to you by purple my friends my goodness
gracious have you been sleeping like
crap lately that's probably because you
have not slept on a purple mattress you
know ever since I've had my purple
mattress I've had the best night's sleep
ever and sleep is important because
guess what eight hours to seven hours
out of your whole 24 hours should be
spent sleeping so you are energized you
are cognitively there the next day and
it should set your mood right so if your
sleep is not right your mood ain't right
and your whole day just goes to poop and
guess what my purple mattress has helped
me with my mood and I have never felt
like poop ever again ever since I have
slept on a purple mattress now check
this out the pro-bowl mattress will
probably feel different than anything
you've ever experienced because
the material has been developed by
actual rocket scientists and I am not
making that up it's not anything like
the memory foam you're used to because
purple my friends has science behind it
so check it out 100 night risk-free
trial if you're not fully satisfied you
can return your mattress for a full
refund backed by a 10 year warranty free
shipping and returns you're going to
love purple and right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text brain to
eight four eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is the text
brain two eight four eight eight eight
that's B R a I n two eight four eight
eight eight yeah it's like the thing is
we got a vet that's all like that's
always what I tell people is you got a
vet you just don't know I didn't I'm not
a lot of like [ __ ] crazy people
here's here's what I do I mean [ __ ] I
don't know if I should let this out
because people don't people will know
what I do and the line [ __ ] scrub
their [ __ ] but I always do this to new
people I mean I'm playing Mafia 24/7
like with new people because what I'm
thinking about is I need to protect my
friends yeah like we have a really
sacred group of friends or whatever and
if something happens uh you know it's
just dangerous
yeah and we're a target like like we're
not super celebs but we are a target
because what people don't understand is
that there are [ __ ] faces out there that
study the content they get into your
circle or they try to get close to you
and they want something they want they
want some type of collaboration they
want to get put on they want money they
want you to invest in their company
these are the things that people people
don't really have to deal with but if
you own a business or if you get some
type of Fame or whatever these leeches
start coming after you so you have to
kind of test them there are such there
are straight [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
that will study the JK crew pretend that
they accidentally came around it's like
[ __ ] I see you from a [ __ ] mile away
but you also have to figure out if these
people have
severe dangerous [ __ ] yeah you don't
want to bring them you don't want to
bring somebody in who's a serial rapist
or whatever in your crew right yeah so I
run background tests on people and they
don't know it but I run it I run that
[ __ ] on people online it's easier now
more than ever and I dig [ __ ] up I stalk
them I have [ __ ] fake cats I tell
people to go and look and see if this
guy gets off of work or or I go onto the
Facebook yeah I look because I'm first
and foremost protecting my friends
because some of my friends are so
innocent
they don't [ __ ] know like they don't
know if this you know that they're just
gonna bring this [ __ ] around and I'm
just like don't do that you [ __ ] you
don't know who these [ __ ] are most in
most cases people check out right mm-hmm
but there are other cases where like
okay this guy has a criminal record what
is it might be a misdemeanor like
domestic of use it might be like I
caught one guy he had a [ __ ] ton of
tickets just driving like violations
that he never [ __ ] took care of mhm
or whatever but in most [ __ ] cases
it's completely scrubbed or like it's
it's fine but I still have to do that
check because there's also compulsive
liars out there that'll be like yeah I
went to this school I did this business
I did that and they don't come out look
people just [ __ ] to be in your
circle like don't be like yeah I've been
you know I went to this school and then
like I [ __ ] I do this job I have this
many businesses and I'm just sitting
there like really wow that's a lot in my
head I'm taking memory alright you have
this and you have that you own this
business ok cool [ __ ] go as soon as I
get home I start searching okay this
person owns it ok he's legit he's legit
all right Coco coz then here's the
dangerous part right is you get excited
meeting this big business guy or
whatever the fun you listen to
everything he says and you go hey David
you know what's [ __ ] cool man I just
met this guy he owns 8 [ __ ] burger
restaurants dude he's so cool let me
bring him around you [ __ ] meet this
guy oh man rule
he's Joe's friend well I should start
working with them you start working with
this guy right and he scams you and you
go what the [ __ ] Joe I didn't know
you I didn't know that yeah so I've made
these mistakes and my friends made these
mistakes in our early 20s right where
there's guys out there there's this one
[ __ ] who claimed to be a big real
estate agent I thought see here's my
mistake is I think people are as a
diligent embedding the way that I am so
if a friend that I really like and trust
bring someone around I automatically
think they work together they're cool
it's their credibility right and then
this real estate guy ends up being a
[ __ ] fraud
I am I introduce them to my other friend
who was selling a store at the time my
friend kept bugging me and saying hey
man none of my [ __ ] is on a listing but
he says he keeps working and I got a
fire this guy because I'm not selling my
store ends up getting sued by the
[ __ ] agent because the agent was
running a he was basically his scam was
he basically claims to be the sole real
estate guy right and he just waits until
they get fed up and then fire him and
that's how he makes his money oh wow
because in the contract he's supposed to
be the main guy that's crazy and if he
gets fired he's like you okay pay up all
the work that I did in the past you owe
me yeah it's yeah and then so I went up
to my other buddy like why the [ __ ] did
you introduce me to this guy I thought
you guys were friends like I'll just
meet him two weeks ago I'm like why do
you talk so big about this guy like you
guys are best friends yeah he's a con
artist you brought a con artist into our
circle of friends and I scolded his ass
and he's just at the end of the day I
was like he is innocent he doesn't know
how to deal with these things but for me
from that point on I was like I don't
give a [ __ ] if I didn't personally meet
these guys I got a vet every single new
person that comes around a circle and
then the funny thing is when I was in
Vietnam I met this billionaire his
assistants already knew everything about
me oh really I was like ooh these guys
are good they're smart they're really
they've vet with the people so I'm I
didn't know he was a billionaire I met
him through a friend of mine who
does commercials so my friend was
working on a campaign for his fall
restaurant right he has a chain of four
restaurants and he's doing like an
all-out three-part commercial for his
ass so he needed to go meet him and he
told him about me a little bit and he
gave him a few links and he says okay
yeah you're gonna really like Joe we get
there and his three assistants knew
every single channel every single
business that I'm into and they were
updating him as we were talking so what
the [ __ ] that's crazy
so I was like you guys did your homework
yeah and I'm like that blew my mind
because I was like when I get back
that's what I need to do is I need to do
my homework on people and this is
different this is business right this is
different from like casually meeting
friends of friends and hanging out with
them but I'm like these guys are on a
different level dude like the the layer
of security and protection and the
veining that they do it's a whole
different game that's that's that's
interesting that you mentioned that
because I watched the did you watch the
Kevin Hart documentary so the Kevin our
documentary I mean not to really spoil
it but if you haven't it's been out for
a while but even even people within his
interpersonal circle right so he has him
in the plastic cup boys which is like
which is just a few guys as people that
he really trusts and Kevin is one of
those people that brought up people
along with him right
and he cuz he wants his circle to be
tight because as he gathers more wealth
more importance there's a lot of people
like you said where there's vultures now
oh yeah that want to take from
everything that you've earned and all
the stuff that you've worked hard for
well for him he built a team around him
that could kind of check him and keep
him in place and that he trusts with
everything so do you remember that time
when Kevin Hart went through that whole
scandal with him cheating on his on his
wife so what actually happened it was
revealed in the documentary which he
never mentioned until this talk he was
actually set up by one of his boys in
the circle oh no so when he went to
Vegas to have a good time and it was
kind of weird where he said you know
lack male dumb so one of the one
the person they blackmailed the
blackmail yeah one of the black males
blackmail the blackmail oh no so he you
know one of his boys who is not in that
group anymore and they're still going
through legal stuff right now he from
what I remember was in cahoots with that
hooker oh that that [ __ ] him and they
recorded that and then he extorted him
for thirty million dollars it was one of
his friends with one of his best friends
since day one within assert that's dirty
isn't that [ __ ] crazy
I would I would kill that [ __ ]
guys I think so I would murder that my
voter did meet up to pay him and murder
him I don't oh my god isn't that insane
a day one homie like that a day one
homie would in his small circle you
think he's been building some type of
resentment toward Kevin probably firm
his success or yes something right
there's got to be some type of
justification that guy has in his mind
to be able to do that for someone he's
known for so long it's they probably
feel like they deserve more for what
they've done to build his empire but the
crazy thing is his other friends don't
feel like that it's just that one guy
like there's Judas [ __ ] so if
you ever go to a Kevin Hart concert yeah
stand-up comedy tour concert or whatever
he has his homies do the opening and he
has somebody who is like the hosts of
the show so this dude said with I
shouldn't know his name because now he's
he's pretty awesome
he prior to Kevin bringing him on he was
broke out of his [ __ ] mind struggling
yeah and then when Kevin Hart hit him up
because yo this is when Kevin was on the
up-and-up because hey I heard you're
struggling I want you to come with me on
why I want to I want to work with you
right the guy that scammed him no no
he's not that guy's not even talking
about he's gone now but he was like he
told Kevin Hart because of his pride he
goes now I'm doing real good dude but he
was struggling he was broke out of his
mind
Wow and then Kevin was like no like I
know you're doing bad like let me let me
help you out yeah and then since then
he's helped build him a career he's now
a producer of like two TV shows and [ __ ]
making his own money yeah
with with Kevin Hart's company I mean I
think that dude really does bring up his
team and is so wild that sometimes even
when you're successful in some people
you out they still feel that they
deserve more yeah and it's cool it's
like well if you deserve more and you
feel like you could do more then leave
his company and do it on your own yeah
nobody's nobody's holding you down I
think that's the problem those kevin has
probably got a big heart and he
continuously gives yeah where I feel
like you got to be a little bit ruthless
to where if someone is ready to [ __ ] you
you got to be able to [ __ ] them harder
yeah that's my opinion
hmm but you you know in his situation he
probably a lot of people what's that in
the imposter syndrome where you feel
like you you don't deserve this give
like an alternate life almost yeah
there's people like that out there right
I don't know if he's like that but his
day one homey might be guilt tripping
them and then I don't know it's it's
it's such a weird and like scary thought
yeah just like that's like me you and
Bart we're chilling then one day you
guys extort me even though I have
nothing like give me your [ __ ]
element you stupid son of a [ __ ] that's
my soul but like that's that
relationships take time to maintain
mm-hmm something could have happened
yeah we don't know what happened yeah I
don't know but yeah a lot of people say
oh man the [ __ ] money and this and
that money makes people [ __ ] up or
whatever I'm like nah man money makes
people's true colors come out mm-hmm it
really does money money tends to [ __ ] up
a lot of things I I think that when when
things are done pro bono it shit's all
free and everybody's just doing things
for fun it's just the art that matters
yeah but once money starts to flood in a
little bit it starts people start going
to this concept of Oh what do I really
deserve now yeah do I deserve more this
do I deserve more than that why do you
deserve that it's like yo [ __ ] dude
it [ __ ] up a lot of things men I kind
of like it
so I like that money brings out people's
true colors and then they have to deal
with becoming better themselves and like
each other right whereas other people
might feel like capitalism and money and
all that stuff
brings out the ugly side of humans so we
should do away with it so then
we don't bring it out and I'm like nah
we should bring out the truth
we should dangle that [ __ ] bait in
front of people's faces mm-hmm so you
see people for what they are and then we
can we can either call them out on it or
we can stay away from these these ugly
guys with masks you know like no I don't
know but that's my philosophy is I want
to see I want to have as much
opportunity to let the ugliness come out
and see what people are made out of you
know I'm really glad though that I went
through a lot of the the personal issues
of dealing with [ __ ] as human beings
because now I can navigate better before
I start getting into bed with new people
yeah so somebody approached me recently
to work on another food concept right
but because I know how I want to work
with people now yeah there are certain
requirements that have to be met and I
never did that before
like before it was like everybody
anybody everybody anybody right and so
you got money come on let's do it
and so for example one of the biggest
things that I've learned specifically
when you get into a partnership of stuff
is to have very not strict but very
specific guidelines like for example
when your returns gonna come in it
shouldn't be like hey when we all come
up together that's when we split the pot
yeah that's way too general there has to
be a certain timeline or a specific
number that has to be hid for when you
get that return if not you'll never get
a [ __ ] return yep end of story period
if you guys ever start a business and
you're doing with the homie and you go
yo when we make a good amount of money
then we'll split it up what's good
amount of money
what is that exact number and I never
knew the reason for an exit strategy
until I learned the hard way mm-hmm you
need an exit strategy because there's
gonna be a time when you're like I'm
done with this business or I'm ready to
move on or what are you gonna do next
yeah even a retirement strategy like
you're not gonna live forever mm-hmm you
can you can build up this [ __ ] laptop
factory or whatever and what if your
kids don't want it mm-hmm
so I always tell people like make that
commitment of when is it good enough
that's more of the better I guess term
instead of an exit strategy but it's
like okay if I make a hundred thousand a
year off of this business
then you know I'll do this or then I'll
hire a manager or then I'll do whatever
but if people just keep working
themselves to the ground they're working
aimlessly yeah even for this food
concept like I think two three years ago
if this person woulda came up with what
they were offering me now then I would
have said yes
because it's basically sweat equity for
a fat amount for for a small spot that
doesn't have a lot of overhead and what
they were telling me is that it's only
gonna cause us a 15,000 startup I'm like
you're wrong it's not 15,000 15,000 for
the equipment you're not talking about
branding employees supplies like there's
so many different there's more yeah
money you got and you also need cushions
so you're really looking at about 60 70
grand yeah you know and he's like oh
like no it's only 15 it's not only 15
like it's about 60 or 70 grand and so
they're also looking for an
owner/operator right I know for just for
an operator just to run it because they
don't want to run it I was like sorry
man you need to owner/operator or you
need a manager that's invested - exactly
and I told them the reason why you need
somebody to run this place and help
figure it out that also has a financial
stake in this is because they can't just
leave it now yep so you just hire
somebody's like I'll just run the place
they can quit and go to another job
you're talking to amateurs then exactly
that's my criteria right so like when I
get into bed with people I go do we
speak to the same language do I have to
be a mentor do they bring their own set
of skills to the table where they're
teaching me some [ __ ] - and so like with
our food concept or whatever right
Jeremy and Anna when we got into the
franchise with them I trusted them
heavily because they built their own
Photo Booth wedding company that they're
basically absentee owners for so what
that means is they don't have to be at
the business they run their business in
the East Coast they live in the West
Coast they work one day a week on their
business maintaining it and making sure
all the managers are running it right
then to me I'm like you graduated to the
point where I trust your business sense
you're not starting from scratch we're
not buying into a dream you guys know
what the [ __ ] you're doing and they have
skin in the game they're putting in
money into the franchise and so we so
are we and I'm
like okay now I feel like I'm running
with a bunch of partners this podcast is
brought to you by keeps my friends do
you feel like you're going bald or do
you even know that there's male pattern
baldness in your family well for me I do
not that there's male pattern baldness
in my family and I don't feel like I'm
going bald right now but what I do
understand that prevention is key and
keeps is gonna help me keep my hair so
the great thing about keeps my friends
it has easier to access to hair loss
treatment prescription medication
delivered at home and even online doctor
consultation here's some facts for you
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they are 35 and guess what you
don't have to go broke to avoid going
bald keeps offers generic versions of
the only two fda-approved hair loss
products out there lucky for you and
once again prevention is key they are up
to 90 percent effective at reducing and
stopping further hair loss so what are
you waiting for
get on it remember if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss goatee
keeps calm / brain and to receive your
first month of treatment for free once
again go to keeps calm / brain and
that's ke PS comp / brain for your first
month of treatment for free where people
make the mistake is let's say you come
up as a business person your first
business you make all this money then
you get all these people knocking on
your door and they're like hey man I got
this [ __ ] idea I got this awesome
idea let's do this
it maybe they got a little bit of
business experience maybe they were
manager at a store maybe they worked in
the industry in the clothing line they
did this or that right which is they'll
talk a convincing game but unless people
have ran their own [ __ ] [ __ ] do not
get into partnership with them if you're
not at the same level if you're all if
you're all at the same level like let's
say you're all starting from the start
and you don't have any business
ownership experience they don't have any
fine make those mistakes together
so yeah and don't expect it to blow up
and if it does great but you're at the
same level and that's a stepping stone
but when you're already an established
business person be [ __ ] careful about
investing into people with big [ __ ]
dreams because in most cases they're
gonna burn your money and they're not
gonna give it back because they're
practicing on your dime yeah and
especially because we also need to have
the same ground of where this business
is going because there's gonna be a
point to where there's gonna be critique
coming into the business right and how
it actually really does [ __ ] up with
perception of how they take in the
critique because it was too close to
home and it's just their personal love
project they're not gonna take critique
very well oh yeah they don't understand
what the business is for so if it's like
for example they go this is my mom and
pop noodle shop and I want it done the
way I want it don't get into business
with them it's the worst idea oh no
unless they're already successful
they're making a lot of money and they
want to expand to another store it's
like oh well this is tried-and-true it
has a huge name I'll invest into it and
get a percentage of what was already
done yeah but if they're starting up
this food project where it's brand new
no name no branding no nothing else and
they're not going to be susceptible to
Yelp reviews critiques changing things
because you know in their mind this is
how they want it done it might be a bad
idea mm-hmm it's kind of a hard thing
and I had to learn that too so they kind
of came to the table with just all the
stuff that I've heard before you know
and it's nice it's a new pitch someone
gave you yeah it's a new pitch and I was
like now because so it's two people who
have done food loosely one guy has money
and they're like this is some easy stuff
it's gonna be okay when people do that
oh it's gonna be easy no it's not man
isn't I don't like that approach that
that to me is like it's very half-assed
I like people who give a [ __ ] about what
they're doing yeah and if it was that
easy if it was easy easy stuff is this I
give you $20,000 and by the end of the
fiscal year you'll get three times back
that's easy that's easy
oh my god yeah me having to come in
teach you guys about branding setting up
a menu looks training staff how things
should be organized how they should be
put out how your Instagram works how
Facebook Ads work then your mentor in a
consultant your
a business partner exactly this is too
much work for me yeah like this is way
too much stuff and then I have to
develop the menu with you I can't do
some sacking today you would have taken
it because the experience would have
been a great exactly for you it's like I
got to go through this [ __ ] again cuz
that's what happened with with drips of
swirls so if you guys know now drips
this world is closed really so just as
squirrels is closed now and you know
when I was telling you all these guys
are these horror stories with business
it was drips and swirls that that's
wasn't that what's going through it but
there's such a magical place no I I
still stand by the product the food was
great if you look at the reviews it was
four and a half stars
that's not my influence that's people
coming in and enjoying what we had so my
so if people like that for what it was
at the time I only got to do 10% of what
I wanted to do with that place maybe not
even that it didn't even really get it
barely got his foot in the door and then
it was stopped because of number one
creative differences from people who
didn't know how to run a business number
two that were doing it on their own
without me so to put it in perspective
that place was making about 50 bucks
maybe a month before I stepped in and
then when we when we enough I think our
first year it wasn't even a full year it
was from summer to the end of the year
it was the gross 250k I'm surprised you
didn't Ray Kroc there ass dog I should
have I would have Ray Kroc there ass cuz
like well that's where the shady side of
me comes in because it's not even shady
it's like okay so the biggest reason why
most businesses fail is the ego of the
business owner yep I've rarely seen a
case like it's rare like it's like a
like a pager store goes out of business
cuz no one wants pagers anymore but at
the end of the day that still goes back
to the ego of the [ __ ] owner that
didn't sell what he should have yeah
I rarely seen any businesses fail yeah
and I've seen a lot of businesses fail
and most of them fail because the owner
is too stubborn they're blaming
everybody else mm-hmm
they're like not adjusting to the tide
and the change and they're just really
hard [ __ ] headed yeah it was hard for
some of the I mean I'm still good
friends with one of them you know
one of them was all those trash stories
that I told you about the guy that
developed the recipes he's still a piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] if I see him in public
it's on site that's how bad of a human
being is like terrible human being like
leaving the employees to go to [ __ ]
EDC and leaving the store alone to
employees who just worked there for a
couple of weeks oh my god what a child
what came back to a meeting that we had
after with [ __ ] like beads around his
neck and [ __ ] neon sunglasses because
he needed to [ __ ] find himself at the
rave huh yeah and he was supposed to be
an owner [ __ ] operator he was sweat
equity and he just bounced and left or
attended to work all the [ __ ] time
used a company card to fund his private
dinners he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] I see you if
I ever see one pair something [ __ ] you
up that says you know [ __ ] bag dude yeah
and then you know some of the other
partners they were too kind to even like
call mounds [ __ ] but then I was not
dude I'm like I don't got time for this
[ __ ] and so you know at the end of the
day with that it was a great learning
lessons because I made I I made those
same mistakes I didn't have an exit plan
I didn't figure out when I can get my
return back and it was just it was great
though like I've learned that number one
I can create a great product number two
people like what I make so I I know what
I'm doing at least in that type of case
right and I think the great part was
when I I really stopped promoting it and
it just it did well based on what it was
yeah the product did well for itself
which was great well usually businesses
fail because of lack of teamwork yeah
there was no teamwork whatsoever once
fighting for their own and you guys had
such a magical thing going on I love the
product I love the look everything but
it just sucks how it had to end you know
like you guys were generating so much
that you lost or made so much [ __ ]
money
yeah but that's how it usually goes man
and they wasted all the money that all
worked on stupid [ __ ] it was dumb but
what I love about these experiences
though is like it sucks but the the part
that people don't get is it makes you
smarter socially more intelligent you're
you're wiser you're just man I could
read a [ __ ] so much faster now
like I could sit down we'll have a
dinner and I'll know immediately if I
want to work with this person or not
yeah and the more you do it the more the
less
the less desperate you are the less
immediate like I don't need a [ __ ]
work with anybody I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're me like a millionaire like I've
met millionaires I met a billionaire
like I don't [ __ ] care I have two
it's like am I gonna be able to work
with this person for years is what I ask
myself is this someone that I can trust
is this do I feel comfortable around
them because people are thirsty bro like
this is what I don't get is people here
oh this guy's successful he has millions
of dollars I'll put up with it but in
reality this guy might be a complete ass
and he uses money to control other
people like you don't know
you take the bait from these
[ __ ] and what ends up happening
is they they control you through the
money that they're giving you yeah and
I'm like I don't like that kind of
relationship I'm not nobody's [ __ ] ho
and there's a lot of people like that
there's a lot of people that you just
gotta realize what the relationship is
and what they're looking for some people
just don't give a [ __ ] about money and
they just want to play with you yeah and
I have friends like that that are just
like I have I'm [ __ ] rich let's go
hang out let's have some long yeah let's
play and I think the more we deal with
this while of business is like I'm
constantly learning about humanity and
how they work and how they treat each
other and through my experience I'm
learning more about myself and what I
want out of people what I want out of
life and it's [ __ ] amazing now other
people when they're getting into this
they get stressed the [ __ ] out but me it
makes me feel alive
like the way I play poker the way I play
Mafia the way I get into this game like
some people might be like oh that's too
political and shady but in my opinion
I'm like I'm not really it's just human
dynamics like people are constantly
wearing thirty different faces or
whatever you know like you have an
interview face you have a face when you
go up to a cashier and you have this
this is what I'm ordering face you have
all these different facets of who you
are right I want to see if we're talking
about business or what these
[ __ ] really want out
me and if I can catch that sooner that's
a little game I play so yeah and I think
it does require somebody to be able to
run a business and step away from it and
not take things too personally to have
it run smoothly yeah because like just
for an example one of the partners who I
just did not get along with I I heard
horror stories after I would leave
because my I'm not an operator of the
place I'm just there to set up branding
and kind of take them to the next step I
write a plan out and they chose not to
execute any of it I'm just so [ __ ]
dumb but came back and you know I would
hear horror stories like for example one
of the girls she was a manager of the
place and she was the the owner was a
hardcore micro manager and it's a
[ __ ] hundred and something square
foot a soft surf shop for crying out
loud right and she was telling me when I
came back she was super upset super
pissed I was like hey like this isn't
usually my job but let me ask you like
what are you so upset about like what's
going on right and she told me that I
was like after she became a manager she
was supposed to get a raise she didn't
get a raise she was in pay for a raise
for a month was like wait you haven't
where's your raise at they're like she
didn't give me a raise and I was like
wait so they gave her a higher title
with no race with more responsible I and
I was like what happened here and I was
like whoa and so her excuse was when I
talked to her she goes well I explained
to her that you know it's a small store
so we're shifting money around and that
we'll pay her I was like no no no no no
that's not how it works if you are
giving her the new [ __ ] position you
[ __ ] pay her period and a [ __ ]
story you're the Chief of Police now but
you're gonna get paid yeah as a normal
cop yeah so she was delayed on her
hunter check like a month and I was like
no you do not give this girl more
responsibility and not [ __ ] pay her
how [ __ ] good and they she was and
she goes well did she tell this is what
she said that blew my [ __ ] mind
she goes well did she she goes well you
know we're friends we have an
understanding this is not your personal
relationship this is her job yeah she
gets paid for her work and so she was
like well I was like a one-sided
friendship too and she's doing you a
favor what are you gonna do back she was
like I helped her move her stuff last
week I was like what the [ __ ] are you
saying this is what does you movie
helping her move her stuff have to do
with her job and her workplace so you're
not gonna [ __ ] pay her cuz you helped
her move her boxes you dumb [ __ ] Wow so
I that that's when I I had I was fed up
with the place I was like at this point
you guys have mixed personal friendship
with work
yeah and either way you have you're
taking advantage of these people yeah
you know and so she got fed up fed up
but then she left
we had another employee let me tell you
this [ __ ] crazy story and it feels
good talking about the stuff since it
was stores closed now this is this is
the funny [ __ ] we had a guy that that
worked there really handsome dude very
nice guy turns out it wasn't really for
him he didn't really want to do it as a
part-time job he wanted to go elsewhere
yeah so the same person who owned this
door got really offended by that got the
saltiest [ __ ] because the guy didn't
want to work there who the [ __ ] cares
right so you know when you're an
employee you get funny yeah you get a
trip since whorls t-shirt cap or
whatever right and so she comes back and
she was [ __ ] like she was asking him
to like return the shirt back in the Hat
back after why exactly why it's like
it's like you're a soldier and they're
like [ __ ] ripping away your [ __ ]
tags cuz you don't deserve it you're
court-martialed and I was like are you
harassing this guy and so he he worked
for a very short time and I think his
paycheck was like fifty or sixty bucks
or some [ __ ] it was like something
really small yeah right and she goes you
need to come in and pick up his check he
goes don't worry I don't really want it
like I don't because she goes no for
legal reasons you have to pick this up
and he goes no no I don't he just mail
it exactly you could mail it or
something else if not just put it into
the tip jar I'll put put like whatever I
don't [ __ ] care yeah right and she
was adamant wouldn't stop harassing this
guy and I and I found out about this
like months later through through
another employee yeah and I was like
your pride is so hurt that you had a
harass so you know what that guy did he
came back returned his [ __ ] and then he
took his check gave it back and he
bought all of his friends free
soft-serve he goes [ __ ] it here this is
what you wanted here take it back I was
like and that's when I was like closed
the store down this is done like you are
impossible you cannot run this [ __ ]
store and so after that point it well we
were planning to close it down it just
took a long time because
for some [ __ ] reason she didn't want
to close it till forever yeah and I was
so pissed I was like dude you're a trash
human being how [ __ ] dare you treat
our employees that way and for me like
I'm not an I'm not a part of that side
so you know they were supposed to come
with the experience and they were
supposed to you know run this thing and
I told them like it's very important for
people to feel noticed and heard their
opinions about a store that they work at
every day is more important than what we
think how the store runs yeah they are
there every day they're in the trenches
so when they talk about stuff that could
be worked on
you don't call them stupid and dismiss
what they say you listen to that [ __ ]
but you're trying to reason with idiots
exactly and you told me that sounds like
you're right I'm done I can't run this
anymore that's when I started feeling
better because I'm I always try to gauge
people where they are in their
consciousness right mmm like obviously
like what I try to do is if I if I were
getting into business with them I'll try
to figure out what every single person
wants out of this and it sounds like
you're your guy partner what he wanted
was another fun business venture to do
with friends right the girl partner it
sounded like what she wanted was a sense
of community and purpose mm-hmm not
business she wanted everyone in a family
and friendship mm-hmm and the artist
wanted his selfish self-expression yeah
so the goals didn't sound like in line
yeah because everyone wanted their own
thing and you probably were cool with
the investor because he lined up closer
to you yeah and now you have all these
conflicting forces because everyone
wants what they want and no one's like a
team and in her case it's like poor girl
like she seems like she doesn't have
many friends because of her [ __ ]
attitude she has no friends right
absolutely no friends so she's here
forcing the togetherness in the
friendship in the [ __ ] she's trying
to get fulfillment of friends family
environment all through that one little
[ __ ] business and she's stubborn as
[ __ ] not realizing that her actions is
pushing everybody away
it's everything was such a personal
thing so for example she was very like
erratic and she would bring up
personal stuff that she would do for
them outside of work as a reason why
they should listen to her it's like it
was it's very Korean it's like I watched
this I did this for you what does that
have to do with their job you know if
you wanted to do that out of the
goodness of your heart you did that at
the heart these are two separate yeah
you can't hold people hostage for the
gifts that you give them exactly and
they were they would be like and one of
the employees like I had to take him
aside and talk to him too because he was
so gung-ho for this for this and I was
like hold on a second I wasn't let me
ask you something and I just told him to
be honest about what's going on in the
store and he was just like well and even
him - he's so hyper Korean he would
mention stuff like she goes well she
bought me lunch the other day I think
she's a great person I'm like I'm not
even asking you about her personality
I'm asking you how the business is run
so even for you as I'm asking you what
the business is run you just mentioned
that she bought you lunch I didn't ask
you about your personal know how to
separate the professionalism and the
business with a personal friendship yeah
and that was the hardest part like like
you're right she wanted it to be like
this family environment but the problem
with her family environment is that
she's head of household you do as I tell
you to do which is terrible it's it's a
terrible work environment and I hated it
I couldn't be a part of a company that
didn't nurture our employees the right
way Yeah right and it was extremely
dogmatic she's a tyrant she's a tired
like young lady's kingj kim jong lady
dude i'm jang unneeded so for her for
example she had this much to drink that
she wanted to serve it was this matcha
shake she was trash people didn't buy it
people didn't [ __ ] like it and we
looked at the sales it wasn't doing well
and I told her hey these sales aren't
doing well let's take it off the menu
she goes well I like it
cool [ __ ] it's wasting money nobody
[ __ ] buying it yes she doesn't listen
to the math she doesn't listen to the
math and even for me I had this like
Captain Crunch shake which I asked
people to create I loved the Captain
Crunch which was great they didn't
promote it
why because not a spite at a spike they
didn't [ __ ] promote it she rather
sabotage the business yeah her ego again
they didn't promote it I asked him to
promote it before summer started so we
can have a secret [ __ ] menu that only
like real drips fan new apron
at the end of summer when summer was
over and there like it didn't do well no
[ __ ] [ __ ] you killed the plan 2020 is
the year where I do not deal with lower
forms of intelligence I just can't deal
with it me neither as soon as I find
that out I'm like but I do like it if
just to bring it back towards me I'm not
perfect I've made mistakes before we
just had a meeting recently and Arjuna
tea meeting where we talked about how
sometimes we're not very responsive to
emails because we get very busy and
inundated with a lot of our personal
stuff we had to own up to that and
apologize right and I think that's the
positive work environment where we don't
make excuses for that stuff
no you just go yeah we drop the ball
sorry
we'll do it yeah and we'll look at it
and I love our Joon B team because every
[ __ ] there is there for the
greater good of the company not to
satisfy their own damn ego yeah and I
appreciate that too so when you know
what at the meeting and and I think what
happened too is that they put so much
effort into these emails and even though
we're busy we open it up and we don't
respond to it
it kind of shows a level of disrespect
that they didn't get from us even though
yeah we did read it but it didn't show
us that we appreciated their work which
was terrible on our part yeah and so now
we're gonna get better with that and
that's the type of work environment that
I like to work at it's where if I [ __ ]
up ya know I gotta say I [ __ ] up and I
saw that some of our partners were and
some of the the people who work on our
social media they're like they were more
kind of hurt yeah and I have to accept
that own up to it apologize and then do
better next time
and it's kind of cool that you are
experiencing both businesses at the same
time yeah cuz hearing your stories in
the contrast it's like you're also
learning from it - yeah oh [ __ ] cuz like
now you know how to appreciate the crew
better but also you know how to manage
if you're in a situation like that again
or what to look out for mm-hmm and and
and through your stories all of us -
we're just like okay we gotta watch out
if that happens you know and so no
experience is I think a bad experience I
think but for me the level as to how
long it was dragged out I think it was
it was really long
yeah a [ __ ] up on this I mean yours
you your do genuinely care a lot that's
why I think it ends up that way because
you want people to improve but um I kind
of know when to cut my [ __ ] losses
that's the thing it just dragged on way
too long it should've ended a year ago
yeah cuz then you debt you end up
damaging yourself from how much you put
into it yeah it hurts me it hurts me
more than hurts them right yeah and and
not caring is a lot better than I think
a lot of our friends are people that are
watching they deal with this a lot is
like you're in a shitty workplace and
you're working and you might be the only
one on the group project that's like
going hard and you feel like no one's
enthusiastic or helping you out even in
businesses like you do have one that
might be pulling most of the weight
while the other partners aren't the
communication has to get better or you
got to get the [ __ ] out of that
situation because the thing is there are
groups out there where everyone's a star
player and everyone's [ __ ] working
hard together and they communicate
better and that's where you got to
search you got to search for that you
got to surround yourself around that
whether it's fact
even within family mmm-hmm like even
within my family man like it's like we
do have a very hard-headed group and we
do have a more self-aware group who
isn't who's willing to take criticism
and change and all that and have a
discussion while the other ones are more
traditional like and they don't like
listening and have critical thinking and
there's like a rift in the family
because as we evolve and we start
thinking and discussing things more we
want to pass that on to the younger
generation we don't want to continue the
more straight up
old-school conservative Asian top-down
talking without thinking you know it's
more like listen to me I'm the oldest
but it's really just too inflated old
man's ego that's like shut the [ __ ] up
man would it we're all adults here we
can have a debate and they don't like to
be challenged so that tells me that
they're not intelligent they're just
scared of having their thoughts
challenged because if you truly are like
you know who the [ __ ] you are it's like
come on test my thoughts yeah right but
they don't like that and it's so me and
my cousins and whatever we're able to
grow as human beings that we
a little group chat together and we talk
about like things that we learn about
ourselves about our family dynamics
things that we like we share books and
all that stuff right and that's the type
of environment that everyone should
strive for is within your family within
your friends within business or the
workplace go for that because there's
something better out there and if you
can't find that and you're constantly in
this dragged out toxic environment you
gotta get the [ __ ] out cuz it's gonna
kill you yeah it's it's it's a big
learning experience man and I think like
I kind of got caught up in I would go to
that soft surplus pot at night a lot so
I know that when we first started up a
lot of people saw me there all the time
yeah and I think what I really enjoyed
was watching people's reaction like when
they would eat it they go yo this is
really good it was magical man that she
loved that [ __ ] that [ __ ] filled my
spirit up and play me hot cheetos yeah
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] fire man and
I'm not gonna even take credit for that
one that was the the [ __ ] swindlers
on MSP boy though he was mad talented
that's a [ __ ] I can't take away from
anything from his talent and credit but
him as a human being as a person you're
a terrible terrible person r.kelly man
yeah yeah you might as well just
kidnapped and pissed on girls did you're
a bad person you know you're going
straight I've never met somebody where I
was like damn you're going straight to
hell dude like if there's a hell out
there you are definitely burning in the
river of myth estoppel ease I mean this
guy's so pathetic he pretended to have a
seizure so he doesn't have to have a
meeting with you that's the crazy isn't
that isn't that crazy that the man faked
the seizures that his mom was there to
pick him up from the floor when she was
when she was in Korea like you dumb
[ __ ] compulsive liars compulsive liar
dude hi hailey [ __ ] I love that [ __ ]
because when you catch them it is the
most satisfying thing in the whole world
Phil Phil Hershel it's so funny dude
yeah I can't I can't I like even [ __ ]
yeah telling that story even sounds so
fake but it's like yo what the I can't
make it up how would I make that [ __ ] up
I'm sorry I didn't come to the meeting
seizure yeah like [ __ ] you had a
seizure at a liquor store and you were
lucky your mom was there so she called
she called the hospital take me to the
hospital [ __ ] what the [ __ ] even told
the guy yo if you went to the hospital
give us the hospital we'll pay for it is
what I said what we said didn't have it
you would it just magically doesn't show
up I hate people that try to prey upon
the sympathies of other people try to
make him feel sorry that is a true
manipulator yeah and even my partner's
lied to me too and I was fed up because
they're like now he's still sick he
wasn't he was fine they just wanted they
just didn't want me to confront him and
I was like you guys are such all of you
are bad words they were enabling him
exactly you guys you guys are all bad at
this and you know what's weird though is
like I get I get I become the bad guy a
lot and you probably do do you probably
do too because at the end of the day
like we fight for honesty right the
honest thing is do is call out this
[ __ ] for lying to you for pretending
that he's having a seizure
which is terrible right manipulating
people's emotions because if it was true
I mean let's say you believed it you'd
be devastated you'd be hurt you'd be
like what the [ __ ] dude I didn't I don't
really like them your that sucks right
he's playing with your [ __ ] sympathy
your emotions that to me is the shitty
part not calling his ass out and I don't
understand the world doesn't work the
way that maybe it just drives me crazy
because I'm just like so if I do this
right I do the thing where I'm digging
for honesty I want I want to confront
people I'm calling out people on their
[ __ ] and I've done that multiple
times and I'm the bad guy yeah and like
how many times has this person lied to
me that when they tell me they have a
seizure the first thing I think of are
you lying again
and it turns out to be true yeah how
many times has he lied to me cuz if it
was the first time you probably would be
all are you okay I would have any
[ __ ] concerned but the first thing I
did was like I don't believe that [ __ ]
and then my partner found out that he
lied [ __ ] called his sister his sister
was like no her mom's in Korea what the
[ __ ] guy
what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] at one
time this guy he was working for me he
he lied about having a multiple
personality disorder
and all everybody in the room was like
oh no I feel so bad and I was like
really tell me how he goes oh man in
high school yeah I already could tell
this was already stretching his lie he's
like in high school my friend she was
sexually assaulted and I said tell me
who the [ __ ] did this to you and then I
just woke up and I was on his driveway
and it was blood everywhere oh my god
and then what is he saying in the whole
the whole room is like captivated right
there like oh man you really got that
guy and I'm all like you guys are
believing this [ __ ] right now he's
like it was blood everywhere there was
police I assaulted a man because I had
to do it he's a [ __ ] hero right and
I'm like well I'm looking at this guy
and I'm like you never [ __ ] beat
anybody in your life you lying sack of
[ __ ]
and I caught you lying and creating
stories so many times in the past like
it's oh my god and I was like really
those are police there and I'm like and
you assaulted someone right um so
where's the police report oh no no no
like they let me go because they a told
him the story I was like they let you go
for assaulting a man and beating him
[ __ ] bloody you you you not only
trespassed on his property
you went to his door opened up the door
remember I blacked out and you almost
killed him and I was like so you there
was blood everywhere you [ __ ] this guy
up and there was no police report there
was no arrest
there was no charges pressed against you
and I was and they were looking at me
like I'm the [ __ ] for pressing this
guy to answer and I'm like you got to
put pressure on a liar this guy's a
lying sack of [ __ ] he's right now trying
to manipulate the whole entire room
making everybody feel sorry for his ass
like he has a mental disorder
he's the mental disorder that he has is
he's a sociopath lying to everybody yeah
he's a [ __ ] lying sack of [ __ ] and
I'm sitting there and I'm like how
[ __ ] dare you manipulate the feelings
of everyone's compassion towards you
right now I was like you lying [ __ ]
sack of [ __ ] it was so funny because
just thought I was such a mean human
being yeah because she witnessed me
pressuring this [ __ ] before because
one time we had a meeting
and he was talking about a situation
with with with one of his
ex-girlfriend's and I know his
ex-girlfriend and he was complaining
about how he just does dis and that for
her and from from what I heard is that
he was a complete [ __ ] thirsty
stalker that did not let go after the
fact that they broke up so in his mind
he's just this gentleman that just keeps
giving right and she's just so like yeah
yeah she's so like not appreciative of
all of his [ __ ] so jess was in the
meeting and I was sitting there and I
was like that's [ __ ] complete
[ __ ] like it hauled his ass out and
I was like you're a [ __ ] narcissist
right you think the whole world revolves
around you like you need to quit that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you stopped being
goddamn stalker I was like you need to
stop stalking your [ __ ] ex because
I'm not gonna allow that [ __ ] at my
company yeah and then I was like you are
no longer allowed to come between the
hours of when your ex is here or
whatever whatever this was like years
ago right and and so at this point I'm
lecturing his ass and then just turns
around she's like you're so [ __ ] mean
and I'm all like look you're gonna
understand who this human being is
whether it's in a couple of months or
later and you're gonna understand why I
speak to him this way yeah and it's like
on the surface it seems [ __ ] up that I
even talked to an individual this way
but you'll see why and then later she
was like okay I get it I get it
so everybody in that room believed that
he assaulted somebody on somebody else's
property almost killed him and the cops
didn't do anything they were captivated
by his [ __ ] story dude I was like cuz
if he's gonna lie that's a pretty bad
lie that has never ever ever ever
happened in the history of man ever dude
this [ __ ] told me he was a 10th
degree black belt in martial arts this
boot and I brought one of my martial
artists buddies around and we all
[ __ ] smart and you know what [ __ ]
dojo did you go to you lying sack of
[ __ ] you're not a temp degree blackbelt
you have any idea how old you have to be
to be a temp to be black belt it's a lot
I don't know MA
Vicki from tech mundo yeah it takes a
long time no he was a [ __ ] temp
degree black belt and he doesn't even
know how to [ __ ] kick an apple off of
someone's head oh you're tipping me
black but you get a [ __ ] ruby red
apple put it on your head and all I do
it mother [ __ ] the lying sack of [ __ ]
dude
and I don't know man it's just when I
just can't take [ __ ] right so like
when I catch people off of their [ __ ]
and I roast them I just go in and in and
in until they stop lying around me or
whatever it is um and when people see
that they're gonna they think I'm such a
bad guy and I'm like I'm protecting you
you [ __ ] like if you're little
smarter about that [ __ ] people yeah it's
so funny to it you know what the thing
about fighting is - if you did it for
that long it doesn't really go away when
I was 270 pounds I could still do a
clean a spinning heel kick
yeah I mean I remember you came to San
Diego yeah yeah yeah I haven't kicked in
ages and we were kicking bags and yeah
and our buddy Noah was surprised or like
David could [ __ ] kick man yeah I did
Tech one though for like [ __ ] eight
something years like it doesn't go away
yeah like like a 10th degree black no I
was a red belt stripe I mean we get to
the black was that one before the Braves
were in the black it was one before the
black I actually uh I caught the flu or
I [ __ ] my [ __ ] up I can't remember which
one it is anymore
but at that time if you wanted to get a
black belt your Saba meme the your table
name which is your master from Korea had
to bring his master to come over to test
you to get black Bo
so that's a legit school maybe was a
legit legit school so I had to wait
another year to get a black belt so I'd
never stayed for another year so I just
was a red belt stripe and I got another
stripe and that was about it
so I didn't I didn't get to get my black
belt but be more ridiculous man it's
funny like you got to see through people
I woke up as what they are and how I
said I woke up there was blood
everywhere
I looked at the faces of the co-workers
they're just they were like captivated
like I can't believe it they were scared
man they're like am I am I in a meeting
with a psychopath and I'm thinking like
this guy is all
little [ __ ] he's a lying sack of [ __ ]
he's never
I've been around killers I've been
around people that are [ __ ] not yeah
like and this guy is a wannabe dude he's
never done [ __ ] ever dawg
I got put into a back of a cop car
because I was around a group of people
that were jumping people outside of a
bowling alley so guilty by association
exactly so how did you not get arrested
for [ __ ] beating the [ __ ] out of
somebody exactly what the [ __ ] are you
talk and I was a youth minister at least
report nothing the [ __ ] are you talking
about it makes no sense I know dude you
could catch people in their lies so
easily man that's such that's let
literally means that he has never been
around anybody who's got [ __ ] up in
their whole life or that he has never
dealt with the cops made that [ __ ] up in
front of me and I'm like I can't believe
you're lying to me cops are not that
nice yeah especially when it comes to
violence like that's that's some
[ __ ] dude that this will tell me
that he he was like once I told him dad
I lost it because he sexually assaulted
my friend oh you had a great speech too
huh they um they let me slide I'm like
shut down like they're giving him five
high five like oh yeah go hero
thanks a lot hero and the [ __ ] the
American flag comes down movie that's
[ __ ] off it's not even like that in the
movies when you assault somebody they
get arrested no matter what exactly so
he even did it that was so funny that
when he threw his fist
I caught it midair I spun him in 360
circle he landed us back a [ __ ]
powder dust came out like [ __ ] out of
your guy
that's how fun illusion he kept I mean
cuz man this wasn't the first time he's
lied to me in my face and other people I
blacked out and I woke up there was so
much blood
I told him shut the [ __ ] up that's the
craziest [ __ ] I've ever heard in my life
right I mean we we've had some it's
eccentric people in our group and I'm
not just saying like JK but in our other
businesses too like we just had
a lot of interesting people and that's
the other side of business that they
don't tell you about is the crazy
[ __ ] that you attract do some
people can lie really well to that oh
yeah and you just you kind of get caught
up into the persona that they're
creating and you're like yo this is a
really good guy and then when you start
working with them you find out through
their behaviors through the co-workers
that tattle on them like oh [ __ ] this
person is a [ __ ] psychopath oh yeah
there are people who you know okay we've
seen this as employees before like
managers that get the job because they
kiss [ __ ] ass yup to the top dogs
mm-hmm but when it comes to the way that
they treat the employees man they
powertrip they're mean they're [ __ ]
stupid I've seen a lot of that go down
and I've seen it go down to my friends
companies too like they don't know that
I'm friends with the owner I just come
in and I'm like getting a drink or I'm
hanging out and then I I kind of watched
a dynamic and then it's like this
manager is a tyrant he's a [ __ ] dick
yeah and then when the boss comes around
big smile
hey man how's it going good yeah [ __ ]
people are like that it's it's hard I
think when like like we mentioned
earlier we kind of we kind of get the
cues now we see it before it happens not
all the time because we'll still get
fooled but at least I think I'm like 80%
there right where I could sniff it out
most of the time so and I love learning
more and more like I just want to be
able to like sees through them like an
x-ray vision I just walk into a [ __ ]
room and I'm like BAM I know you
[ __ ] I know you I know I know
you I just want to make a shirt this is
there's blood everywhere listen I've had
tempers before I've never blacked out
and beat the [ __ ] out of somebody like
I've definitely gotten so angry where I
saw red and I started getting into a
fight he said he said that's all red it
was blood and I'm all like it's so
convenient
how you blacked out were the most
crucial [ __ ] details of the story is
left out and you just zoom past the end
and you're in the front front lawn with
a guy beaten down wow yeah where were
these cops huh like I've never do we
shot a Jay case get back in the
where we had just like we were screaming
outside as a sketch and the cops came
and they pulled up with their guns like
that you know to me that we barely got
away with that Shh I don't know man
that's [ __ ] funny man yeah oh [ __ ]
well ya know that hour and 15 in oh wow
it was good yeah well guys people for
who they really are yeah man that's what
we kind of stayed on topic hell yeah I'm
pretty [ __ ] good
well guys you guys can catch the genius
brain podcast on every audio platform
remember we are there to be there with
your commute and just talk [ __ ] out hey
remember if you see this on youtube
write stuff in the comments below
remember to check out Joe's stuff too
thank you very much so Molly and Academy
for anybody out there that wants to
start a new life and I know for a fact
especially because I've just had
conversations with people recently when
they listen to that podcast all 90 days
to freedom 90 days to freedom that it's
so meant it's so [ __ ] crazy like what
we were talking about on that podcast
there are certain people that I'm trying
to help out kind of get their own stuff
started it's literally that problem
right it starts with themselves you know
it's that three reasons why they can't
do something and only one reasons why
they can yeah and it's like [ __ ] you if
you can't break that first part you're
not gonna do anything else it doesn't
matter what I tell you it's like I'm
putting water into a into all empty hole
yeah you know and I that's why I created
the program is because for all these
years people have been asking me the
same exact [ __ ] how do I find motivation
how do you do it how do whatever okay
and I figured out the formula and we'll
see we're gonna have a graduation soon
in a couple of months tight and I'm
gonna see the results of the students
and I'm gonna just I'm gonna take a ton
of survey I got about a thousand
something students and I want to make
the best thing out there that can help
people achieve what they want out of
life you know I love it 90 days to
freedom check out the genius brain
podcast if you guys want to be the first
to leave topics of on genius brain
follow me on the patreon I'll see you
guys next time
Joe we'll see you all next Thursday and
peace base
I wanted to do the topic I'm like dad